what up space fam goals in here for
anime uproar and today I want to talk
about the four Archangels and their
powers we already have a video about the
seven sins and their powers explained
and the Ten Commandments and their
powers explained and you guys really
enjoyed those so I thought I'd add this
one to the collection
the four Archangels are super relevant
in the anime right now so I thought it
would be a good time for this video if
you like seeing seven deadly sins
content on this channel make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is very important ring that
notification bell so that you actually
get notified when future videos come out
for more seven deadly sense content and
crucial updates about the new season
make sure to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar leave
suggestions for future videos you would
like to see in the comments keep in mind
there will be manga spoilers ahead
you've been warned now without further
ado let's jump into it the four
Archangel are supposed to be the
strongest members of the goddess clan
aside from the supreme deity herself and
arguably Elizabeth they're definitely
the strongest goddess team they are the
supreme deities version of the demon
King's Ten Commandments just as the
demon king has given a commandment to
ten specially selected warriors so too
has the supreme goddess given a grace to
each of these four Archangels we'll be
looking at each one of these Grace's in
this video
although the commandments outnumbered
the Archangels according to the
Archangel thar meow each one of the four
Archangels has about as much power as
two of the commandments although in
reality some Archangels are much
stronger than others and we'll get into
that later so let's start with the
three-headed Tarmey o-tar Miele along
with sorry L used the Move Omega Ark to
kill countless demons at once the move
allows him to trap demons in large
spheres of light within which they are
disintegrated by the light particles
Tarmey l can easily regenerate after
having his full body cut in half by GLE
and furthermore when Galan tries to
sneak up on him Tommy is able to launch
a light attack from one of his side
heads that knocks Galan back his other
head sends their iary back with a
similar attack while the main body
charges up his stronger arc attack
despite being outnumbered
tauriel and sari L are able to hold
their own against moan speed Guerrieri
for
Geron angle and until lunar shell shows
up to a system but then it's too uneven
and mon speed and airy area are forced
to awaken in Deraa mode to keep up
turmoil specific race is called ocean he
can use it to become water himself in
this way he can avoid damage from
physical attacks since it's just like
the opponent is punching water he can
create giant spikes using water and
impale his opponents he can also create
an ocean on the battlefield in this way
he can potentially drown his opponent
this is truly some next-level
waterbending
this attack is especially effective when
used in conjunction with sorry ELLs
grace tornado together they can create
more TExES of water and wind that can
tear opponents apart when the two
elements are combined they also produce
lightning their finishing move is called
an Leal's divine retribution and it
creates a huge concentration of
lightning bolts that can molecular eyes
an opponent aka make them disintegrate
this attack was supposed to finish off a
powerful opponent like esta rosa but he
consumed yet another commandment and
gained even more power turmoil and sorry
el are extremely powerful and are even
able to force an Estero so with two
Commandments in a power level of 88,000
to eat another commandment although they
put up a good fight up to this point
they are no match for an S Rosa with
three commandments so next up is sorry
el along with his powerful architects he
has the grace called tornado as
mentioned we got a good sneak peek at
him since he often teams up with Tarmey
el but let's take a closer look at him
now if the big Tarmey el is a
waterbender too small sorry el is an
airbender except his attacks seem to be
much more destructive than a lot of
exits acts from Avatar The Last
Airbender
for instance sorry el straight up cuts
through people's bodies with his
razor-sharp wind attacks he can even
create a barrier around him a fast
moving wind that will cut anything that
tries to get close to him although this
doesn't stop derrière e from hitting him
in the face with what's left of her arm
not gonna live that was an epic moment
sarios attack called piercing scythe
wind creates a giant sight out of wind
that will cut straight through tough
opponents obviously as the name suggests
sorry el can also create especially
destructive tornadoes that as we saw
work well in conjunction with tar
miele's ocean grace
we have luteal shell and His grace flash
blue Rochelle is extremely strong he's
so fast that it often looks like he's
teleporting rather than moving even in a
human body his power level is 200 and
1000 flash grants Laura shall SuperSpeed
think the flash from DC Comics except he
can also fly even daytime s can or
cannot help but notice how fast the lure
shell is in Margaret's body using flash
blue shell is able to cut off s Kannur
shirt before the sin of pride can even
respond
Laura Shaw can also shoot lasers of
light that will effortlessly make holes
in powerful demons like gland when Laura
shell shows up to fight the commandments
he quickly overpowers fraud jungle and
dairy re animal speed forcing the latter
to to transform into Endora against
zelgius lunar shell proves to be
extremely fast and skilled with the
sword zelgius has the fastest
swordsmanship in all of the underworld
but new rochelle manages to outdo him he
gets two cuts on sell dress including a
deeper one on his arm walls I'll just
just got one superficial cut on Ludo
shell during this match lunar shell uses
the move gold shining with this move his
grace flash allows him to produce a
brilliant light that is supposed to burn
his opponent but zelgius what the demon
Kings power is not affected by it
Laura shell can even form a large sword
of light to use in battle along with
this he can use the move breath of blast
which empowers a desired target usually
used on humans the target becomes
brainwash and will continue to fight for
the goddesses with no regard for
injuries or death that's it for a little
shell and his powers in this video but I
may get into more specifics about his
actual level of strength and how he'd
fare against the other characters you
know how strong his lunar shell video
let me know if you'd like to see that
video in the comments now we move on to
the last strongest and most mysterious
of the Archangels I said there were
manga spoilers in the beginning mostly
because this archangel is at the center
of one of the biggest secrets in the
entire series in the beginning we are
told that Maya was killed by aster Ossa
miles graceful son as Lucia explains his
powers grew with the Sun and he boasted
a strength that even Ludo shell couldn't
keep up with by the time noone Droon
here as it turns out that grace is the
very same as Eska Knorr power sunshine
it waited millennia to pick its new
owner
ESCA norm of course we eventually find
out the truth that Esther Olson didn't
actually kill mile he is mild and it was
go through who actually had a part to
play in casting a giant genjutsu that
tricked everybody mile eventually
regains his memories and he even regains
his grace temporarily for a brief period
of time
ESCA noir life smile borrows sunshine to
help his friends and then we had a
glimpse of what mild the strongest
Archangel was able to do with his grace
miles awesome son attack is called
greatest son he shoots a giant Sun at
the extremely opie original demon and
that single attack that feeds him he was
kicking everyone's butt up to this point
and mile absolutely crushed him he then
fight zelgius His grace causes heat to
be released from his body and that he
alone melts soldiers a sword mile
creates energy disks at the ends of his
hand and uses them to take out zelgius
son is evidently the most powerful grace
especially at noon it allows s Kannur to
enter the one mode and the ultimate one
which we've seen recently in the manga I
still wish we got to see miles the one
mode though since in theory he should be
able to access a similar opie form at
noon and that is it for today's video
all four Archangels and their powers
explained let me know who your favorite
Archangel is and why in the comments
also let me know what you think about
the supreme deity in the manga recently
we've been seeing a lot of the demon
king but we still haven't seen the
supreme deity do you think we're gonna
see her before the story ends and what
do you think her original power is
anyways I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is super
important
hit that notification bell or else you
won't know when you seventh at least
sends videos come out
for more 7le sense content crucial
updates follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar a big thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help make videos like this
one possible I especially want to thank
our pro here or tear patrons the one and
only gilgamesh baby ray
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius fit edala beat Anatoly kazansky
DJ Nathaniel and alpha do and are the
one tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans Steven and Rada
allo lon autumn Maddy Mac 239 makoto-kun
and the world if you enjoy our work you
can support more by going over to
patreon calm and me uproar and becoming
a patron today for as little as one
dollar if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord
so check out patreon.com and may uproar
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you will get the
same great benefits thanks for
everything and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]